Anyone can have
a deeply messed up family,
but to have a reality show
as successful as the Kardashians
or the Duggars
or the Honey Boo Boos
you need that special twist.
Could be a handsy brother
or racist grandpa
or just being obsessed with fame
at any cost. Who knows?
So, comedians, I'm gonna show
you some famous families,
and I want you to give me
the name of their TV show.
All right, first up, the Smiths.
The Smiths. Yes, Reggie.
The Fresh Prince of Rylon 7.
Points. Points.
Next up, the Jolie-Pitts.
The Jolie-Pitts. Rachel.
Eight is Not Enough
and Will Never Be Enough.
Points. Very good.
I think it's nice they adopted
an adult Asian man, too.
Very well dressed.
Next up, the Trumps.
The Trumps. Emo Philips.
Well, I don't know
what the show's gonna be called,
but it's gonna be
groundbreaking.
Yeah.
Oh.
Goddamn it.
Goddamn it. Yes.
Next up, the Cyruses.
The Cyruses. Rachel.
Zero Simple Rules
for Dating My Teenage Daughter.
Points. Points.
Next up, these horses.
Emo Philips.
How I Trampled Your Mother.
Yes, points.
Points.
Next up, the Tylers.
The Tylers. Rachel.
Talented-ish.